ja ich begrüße die heutige sitzung in
der wir uns erstmal gut wir es immer tun
nochmal zurück wänden auf einen treffer
sitzung obwohl heute das thema ökologie
der digitalität zentrum steht
ich habe immer schon wieder mal bin ich
darauf zu sprechen gekommen dass es
glaube ich in meiner autoren das
zentrale thema eigentlich
worum es geben bei digitalität dass man
den sein status bestimmten muss aber wir
wollen heute jetzt trotzdem nächsten mal
noch mal zurück blicken auch die
vorletzte sitzung unter ging es um das
thema dimensionen
das war ein ästhetisches phänomen sie
zieren sich ganz computerspiele die hier
gezeigt hatte
wo man den eindruck hatte man wirklich
aufgesogen in dieses spiel in einem 1001
das ist also in version
[Musik]
phänomene und entscheidend ist doch dass
beide versionen auch die frage immer
eine rolle spielt was ist es da
eigentlich in das wir einbezogen werden
ist das nur eine simulation ist es eine
imitation ist es infektion wenn wir zb
romane lesen werden wir in eine fiktion
1000er hat in der summe fiktion zu tun
wenn sie von virtueller realität reden
meinen sie dass es sich dabei nicht nur
um infektionen haben die zahlung etwas
stärker ins komische und das wird ganz
spannend als auch die ontologie lenkt
eigentlich immer mit allen fragen
zusammen die wir hier kontexte die
vitalität
diskutiert sie sehen auch wenn man auf
youtube aber dass ich neues design jetzt
weiß ich habe jetzt die das kamera
fenster direkt jetzt in die folie
einbezogen nicht mehr verraten sind ja
auch ein paket geben
im internet und das
so das war erst der computerspiele und
jetzt in der letzten sitzung haben wir
die digitalität tagung nach gesprochen
ich fand dass man sehr interessante
veranstaltungen und oben rechts mache
ich jetzt auch noch den link zur
playlist dieser veranstaltung und
sie können sich das alles oben rechts im
fenster
nach schauen ehrfürchtig schnitt
versprochen hatte noch einmal eine
kleine digitale presseschau geben
wir haben mehr oder weniger oder genauer
gesagt eine twitter spielen also die
wichtigsten in meinen augen wichtigsten
mediale resonanz wir vorstellen die
diese tagung gewirkt hatte und dazu
möchte ich sie behindert ich will jetzt
ein paar ausschnitte anschauen sich zu
überlegen wo winde steht die
besonderheit der twitter diskussion
das sind das also unter einer bestimmten
zeit vorgelesen und wurde unterscheidet
sich diese später diskussion von der
traditionellen medialen diskussionen zum
beispiel könnte man da an leserbriefe
denken
könnte man gewiss foren denken internet
selbst oder auch von einer ganz normalen
diskussion die man unter vier oder sechs
oder acht oder wie auch immer mehr
frauen für schauen sich das mal unter
diesen fragestellungen und überlebens
sich in liefen da nicht doch auch eine
neue dimension ins spiel kommt die durch
die digitalität bedingt ist oder ob es
nur eine fortsetzung ist die gar kein
unterschied erklärt bedeutet zu der
gewöhnlichen - kann man das hier
einigermaßen klar das ist ein bisschen
vorlese auf youtube sieht man schmeckt
besser und zwar das ist ganz lustig das
ist der achsel komme zudem mache ich
jetzt auch oben rechts den link zu
seinem förderer kleinen auto tage
gehalten hat der achse komme schrieb das
ist ein dozent der didaktik pädagogen
aus erlangen nürnberg und der schrieb im
vorfeld der tagung wir nun auch verhängt
ein wikipedia verbot von hausarbeiten
wie soll das mit der kultur der
digitalität vereinbar seien
es wird sicher sehr spannende münchen
das war also mit blick auf der tagung
nach diesem versteckt er hat er erstmal
link den link zur tagung hier richtig
gut an denn dann halten sie die
gesetzten automesse auto misst die
organisatoren gewesen den verband von
einem namen verwenden und quelle youtube
video hier sehen wir es also direkt aus
diesem zahl das war als ich in der
ersten stunde etwas zu hause bleiben
gesagt hat habe ich gesagt nicht aus
wikipedia zitieren und hier unten sehen
sie kann man es sehen können sie aber
auf youtube gemacht und sie schafft
genauer sehen sehen sie dann hier und es
wurde geteilt sechs davon einer von mir
retweet heißt also eben teilung es wurde
mitgeteilt sechs mal
es wird im 2
und zwar hier sieht man geben und wenn
man genauer hinschaut sieht man dass es
dann 14 kommentare dazu grab das war
eine ziemlich große diskussion und ich
habe davon zu spät mitbekommen weil ich
auf twitter bis dahin noch gar nicht so
aktiv waren
das hat man mir auch sein bewusstsein es
waren rein geld bedeutet eingeleitet
werden diese tagung weil ich gemerkt
habe mit der wissenschaft findet die
diskussion immer auf twitter stadt und
mich über die youtube das ist ganz
interessant also bitte auch meinen
nutzer hier einfach einschreiben
1 kommentar wie sie sehen aber ich
glaube wissenschaftlich ist das medium
das den diskussionen der twitter und ich
habe das natürlich auch mir sitzen
lassen ich hab natürlich dann bisher
verspätet dann stellung genommen hat
dazu geschrieben das verbot als
wikipedia verwoben ist natürlich nicht
generell gemeint ist kommentiert wie
immer auf die medienkompetenz waren
ersten blick ist es wikipedia
orientierung immer sehr sinnvoll
das mache ich selbst auch in mainz
art forum hat dann sinkt reingemacht wo
ich liebe erzählt hatte hierbei der sind
erinnern sie sich noch daran wie wir
kurzen artikeln aus wie liebe hinter
gebracht was die version mit den besten
sinne und hab dann eben darauf verwiesen
dass ich zweimal und im geschäft haben
rate ich ab also ein grund war eben wenn
sie was wissenschaftlich zu tieren zb
emissionen dann dürfen sie daraus sage
ich wiederhole ich hier doch mal
ankommen dürfen sie im einzelnen nicht
wenn sie im begriff definieren auf
wikipedia zu ergreifen weil das einfach
nicht wissen schafft was genug ist
werden sie jetzt aber was anderes
zitieren wollen zb wenn sie eine
hausarbeit über wikipedia schreiben und
dann ein beispiel aus wikipedia bringen
dann dürfen sie natürlich aus wikipedia
zitieren also bitte es ist immer die
frage unter welchen gesichtspunkten
wikipedia und rezitieren zahlen können
wenn sie aber mit pia als
begriffsdefinition lexikon verwenden
wollen können daraus erster hand zitiert
wollen dann erwartet davon hat
die bessere integriertem auch die messe
ein beispiel für seine beste quelle im
internet ist ist im force india auf den
17 std
klicken sie alles torsten wustlich
das ist einschlägig gemerkt können sie
guten gewissens zitiert wenn sie jetzt
aber ein beispiel wie gesagt wenn sie zb
damals um version skala auf wikipedia
darstellen dann können sie natürlich
direkt aus zutaten sind wenn sie
irgendwie irgendwas problematisch ist
aus reggae dance team klar aber es ist
einfach nicht so gesichert wie andere
artikel und es finden sich auch viele
fehler mit dem e-tron ich auch selbst
auch schon die kleinen auch andere
kanäle zu haben diese fehler zu
beseitigen
ich habe da also bestimmt schon 20
artikel kommentiert der regen im
hebräischen für diese dienstleistung
wird dann auch überhaupt einmal
gedankt und so aber das ist alles wirken
das heißt nicht dass es schlecht ist und
es doch gar nicht dass es nicht
irgendwie teil unserer kultur ist
wikipedia ist vielmehr teil unserer
kultur geworden lebens eigentlich als
jedes andere lexikon ohne frage aber wie
es gehen mit allem so ist im internet
ist in entwicklung ss hybride es ihm
schnell in der schnellen veränderung
begriffen und deswegen muss man immer
schauen konnte wegen gesichtspunkten
anders verwendet natürlich auch er
schwebt man kann immer sehr gerne nutzen
zur ersten orientierung da ist es
wunderbar es ist ganz toll das mache ich
immer oder früh zu erfinden verwaltern
quellen gerne store aber eben nicht als
endpunkt sind meistens ein anfang
also hier hat sie eine diskussion
entspann ich glaube es war ein bisschen
missverständnis also ich wollte damit
nicht sagen dass man sich nicht
verwenden soll also nur dass es nicht
die autoritativen quelle auf die wir uns
beziehen können das ist glaube ich
probleme schließung
das ist kann man nachweisen es gibt
natürlich auch aufsätze die sind besser
auf einzelne aufsätze aus wikipedia sind
tatsächlich sehr gut sie sehen das daran
dass es dann also häufig so
auszeichnungen geben dann in spa
wikipedia sohn
die nutzer können darin artikel bewerten
gibt es anzeichen
es gibt es auch aber in der regel sind
die nicht ganz so toll aber das wollen
wir auch gar nichts sein sami khedira
kicken wollen einen guten überblick
geben erster objektiven einfach
verbindlich informieren aber auch erst
recht so und jetzt gab's noch so ein
diskussionspunkt von jemanden der betrag
dann die tagung das war sowie ein ende
der tagung und der stimmt gefühlt sie
zuweilen digitalität alle den ganzen tag
mit vorträgen und gucken sich andere
leute wahrscheinlich dass so ziemlich
das gegenteil zeitgemäße bildung
zusammen er hatte eben jemand eine
geldforderung gesehen die vom publikum
gemacht wurde im tagungsraum und die
zeit geben es da sorgen
und hinterher gab's für den polosport
investiert so wie man es bei mir sind
auf youtube und das war natürlich
missverständnis sei denn ich habe dann
auch gleich freundlich wie ich bin
obwohl das hier schon sechs likes hatte
gleich zu bestimmen wir haben hier nicht
ein ganzes spektrum an medien.de ton auf
der digitalität eingesetzt die mischung
macht weiß wen ich zählen kann
ein mann steht wieder lehmanns
diskussion link gibt zu der befristung
damit will ich sagen dass es nicht noch
besser gegangen werden aber das war
definitiv keine große vorgeschichte die
haben auch mit zu den würfeln die leute
mit einkommen
dann gab es eine diskussion zum
anfüttern keine grenze zwischen kulturen
digitalität aufzubauen ist unsinnig
nutzer genau gleich wie die christliche
religion ein
zwischen körper und seele denke das
macht die vitalität eine eigene
dimension wort digitalität als variables
entwicklung oder erweiterung der
kulturen schlüssel gabriel
ich habe eben die frage aufgeworfen ist
digitales zuhause eine dritte natur da
habe ich darauf antworte wieder prima so
freundlich vitalität setzt angestrebten
reform an so dass sie diese 3
informiert hier herrscht also kein
journalismus
diese transformation neue realität
mitzubringen
die zeitlupe zusammen das ist auch das
thema der heutigen sitzung fragen nach
dem unternehmen hat der nutzer
ausgeschrieben oder kritik auf die
vitalität ist teil der kultur und wer
hier unter logisch differenzen heller
erhöhte unterschiede seine eigenen
dasein des quartal weil es unterstellt
wird dass es zwei welten geben ein
realer eine virtuelle entspannte fragen
kann ich dazu geschrieben
wer wird der betrieb der virtualität
umfasst auch kulturelle form
institutionen virtuelle realität ist
nicht nur digital aber digitalisierte
virtualität scheint einer anderen raum
zeitung zufolge
insofern stellt fragen nach
und theologie der nutzer hat sich im
punkt getroffen dass man das dem könnte
mir nicht sagt bettina tor dann ist es
ein ganz eigenes reich aber das schließt
natürlich nicht aus dass das auch
übernachtungen gibt oder mit dem wie der
zweiten möchte ich einfach aus
diskussion stellen ich glaube dass hier
noch nicht absolute klarheit herrscht
das ist ein wir sind noch ganz am anfang
einer technischen untersuchung erklärung
von beginn an mitwirkten
es gab durchaus nennt diese diskussion
wie ein tweet ein weiteres beispiel wie
die natur in digitalität verschwimmen
und man sieht es vielleicht nicht so gut
als möglich das vorhaben
sind die fronten eines vorteil hier ist
die twitter an
und hier hat jemand dann noch mal
aufgerufen für den tempel
auf youtube sieht ich fand es sehr gut
die verschaffen
das ist praktisch wäre der beste das
beste gegenbeispiel zu diesen tweet von
hiervon wissen nutzer weil es eben zeigt
das jedoch durchaus der verbindung
garten
es ist war eben schon hier verschmelzen
die natürlich immer plätzen und geht
dann meistens noch hier
ich habe ein bisschen den vortrag von
nida rümelin bisschen romantisiert also
kann ein digital organismus die ihnen
professionell vertritt das phänomen und
die chancen der digitalität angemessen
befassen
wir schieben seine theorie das haben wir
diskutiert hier ein bisschen zu
konservativ zusammen also alles eher
digitalisierung er als gefahr angesehen
ich glaube es wird dem phänomen der
digitalität nicht gerät das relativ
vagen aufgeworfen hat jetzt nicht so
eine große resonanz bekommen
wir stehen an einer dinge schon gerade
die internet
digital über diese funktion deaktivieren
wir sollten die chancen mehr betonen
noch mal fasziniert und version die
darin kritisiert das war während seines
vortrags leyen kritisiert biologischen
probe und animismus im bereich der
digitalisierung war was bedeutet dass du
das
als mir hat da so ein bisschen die frage
die antwort auf die frage was die
vitalität gefehlt nieder roden hat sich
recht dass man die mittel problematische
tendenz kritisieren wurst animismus
bedeutet dass künstliche intelligenz
wegen zugesprochen wird und das ist so
was zb irgendwie der ray kurzweil
das habe ich in der bezeichnung der
sprecher eine singularität die nahe sein
er spricht davon dass wir ich weiß nicht
was unsterblich werden ich weiß nicht
dass ich nicht verspricht ganz tolle
dinge glaubt ganz tolle dinge würde
nichts passieren und in den händen des
des silicon valley ideologie finde ihn
sehr treffend begriff aber man darf eben
glaube ich nicht die die vitalität
verkürzen auf diese touristen oder messe
gitarristen das sind ist ein rand
spektrum das ist auch was das dazu
führen oder sich im postkommunisten aber
es geht dabei nicht auf das ist das
entscheidende
und deswegen glaube ich muss mir so ein
bisschen ist aufpassen dass man ihr sie
mit und findet und nicht zu schnell das
ganze überhaupt tun
ja so ein spiel macht es nicht direkt
aber ich glaube man muss ein bisschen
lockerer an die sache ein bisschen noch
konstruktiver ansehen
damit gab es dem riesen sony so also für
den bahnvierer hat ein vortrag gehalten
über das internet als marktplace also
der dienstag - auch in die neue struktur
und also viele wackler ich mache
fördereinrichtungen run hat eben gesagt
wieso seien positiv ist weil eben nur
mit statistiken auszuprobieren und da
habe ich das
wieso
[Musik]
was du brauchst du bist du
aufmerksamkeit bekommen ja was sagen sie
dazu
gibt es hier das neue system das alter
das neue gold bitter sagt sie
ja
eine besondere
zudem sprengte zeichens bruder irgendwie
jetzt sind inzwischen aber dazu müssten
einfach ist die diskussion auf kreative
thesen sind
der platz jeden unter sichtlich eine
vorzubringen ein argument auszuführen
dass wenn dann weiß man er auch
beispielsweise in zeiten zu bilden
müssen
wie viele zeichen sind es nochmal genau
bei und ich glaube 242 geld und man
bekommt das dann angezeigt wenn man so
kurz vorm ende ist wenn die zeichenzahl
ausland gibt es sogar zum 10 9 18 mond
das symbol dann sieht man jetzt messen
lassen also sie sagen daraus würde dann
folgen dass es weniger raum hat zur
entfaltung dem gedanken das argument sei
nur tack tack tack und interessant war
erst eine delle verbänden war es der
gronauer oder der lampe einer meinte die
sonst so ein bisschen wie luther und
gewesen
hier sieht der verband kann man doch ich
finde dass es berechtigt ist das alles
so eine entwicklung auch ein bisschen
mit dem thesenanschlag und dieser
medialität der gutenberg galaxis dahin
der soziale friede oder auch fallen für
die gestaltung von spenden sind
der galaxis galantes gibt es jetzt eine
twitter galaxis könnte aber bei
erfolgreicher unternehmer
[Musik]
ja richtig
die sind alle von dir den thesen die
sind wenn luther da noch ein bisschen
mehr platz gehabt hätte und er hat das
ja auch seine 95 thesen hat er ja in
ganz verschiedenen werke in wir
schriften der babylonischen
gefangenschaft der kirche eben seine
schrift betreiber des christenmenschen
in anderen werken hat er diese thesen
ganz ausführlich begründete der sprint
gehört die unfreiheit des menschenbildes
die svp trio dann mache ich auch nach
oben rechts sitzen den kleinen zu meinem
seminar
mit erasmus also zum lutherjahr 2017 wir
finden sie die playlisten rechts können
sich alles nachschauen
moderne wichtig die thesen sind sagen
die die spitze des eisbergs an ihnen
sagen oder vielleicht auch das ist das
was nach außen drängt und deshalb im
schlepptau wurde ganz am ende trennten
aber für die rezeption denn ist es
glaube ich schon entscheiden wer die
besseren thesen zu setzt als es auch
nicht kunst es den kunst zb im boden
twitterer tag anzuschreiben
also wie würden sie denn sagen muss man
einen twitter-beitrag schreiben damit
der erfolg ist und es an
oder anders gefragt kennen sie einen
berühmten bekannten politiker der das
besonders gut beherrscht
donald trump genau ich mache jetzt habe
ich fast meine fünf verlinkung
möglichkeiten für youtube ausgeschöpft
ich glaube zimmer bei fünf oder sechs
wenn ich man kann nur nach youtube fünf
oder sechs verlinken
wenn du einen flinken noch freies mache
ich jetzt oben den vorlagen der
hartlauer aufnehmen oder malt er eben
weil die reben war es der eine
geisteswissenschaft haben mal die
twitter posten donald trump analysierte
hochinteressant einmal gab es nicht
konnten mit der korrespondenz mit dem
mit dem nordkoreanischen präsidenten an
der ging es darum wer die größere
atombombe hat und er meinte dann trank
ich habe noch eine größere und die
funktioniert und das hat dann hat er
eben mit der emser depesche bismarck
verglichen ganz interessant weil sie das
ist das thema durch meine teams und ich
glaube dass die zukunft
da muss man wirklich noch ein bisschen
mehr
er sieht auch hinterher sein da gibt es
ganz neue dimensionen ja sehr emotional
das angebot gelte es auch noch genauer
gesagt ja das ist völlig die zeichenzahl
bedingt wie sie sagen dass es nur thesen
hatte gästen wie sie glaubt auch zu
recht sagen dass es auch eine ganz
emotionale polemisch erwerben
[Musik]
in estland ein twitter über die gefahren
wenn man das ganze habe dass mich das
sehr verkürzte wirtschaft bisher
verkürzten nachrichten sehen und das
lässt natürlich wieder zu einem kurzen
nachrichten botschaften zu antworten da
ist es natürlich einen trend auf seine
gesamtzeit politische willensbildung des
normalen menschen finden aber schon mal
stattfindet ja viele der stadt ja das
sagt das dass das grundgesetz mit
ausbildung
das macht mir große sorgen jeder punkt
also sind sie politische dimension
ich werde auch weil sie mich ins lot
bringen in einer sitzung die eigentlich
der kultur der digitalität gewidmet sein
sollte werde auch die politik den
digitalen thesen eine sehr gute frage
nach der bereinigung der man sagt ja
auch die medien sind zur sondern vierten
gewalt geboren kann das ganz hinter erst
und anziehen kann sicher sein
nach untersuchung die die rettung
schwierig machen 1/22 jeder gleichzeitig
ein haus in einem debatte was eine große
finden kann wenn jetzt nur zwölf
getrennt
die hessische für fantasie
nur ein paar kurzen bei den kosten
beteiligen
klara spekuliert
es ist uns lieber zusammen würden wir
hier
genau wie dort knapp ich hab den
eindruck weil twitter das immer was
sagen können dass er immer eine meinung
abgeben können diese meinung kultur
jeder musste meinung haben zu allem
hauptmänner vielleicht keine ahnung hat
und wissen sie dass harry wörz der
bekannte künstler für
die sind tendenz einfach was zu sagen
damit gesagt ist ohne dass eine wirklich
diese argumentative ganz interessiert
jawohl jetzt habe ich leider wirklich
alle definitiv meine bedingung
möglichkeiten ausgeschöpft wenn ich noch
eine hätte würde ich oben rechts ein
link zu meinem seminar reformen des
unmoralischen einmal eine sitzung dem
thema lügen und schild damit getan
sonst mache ich zum 1 also kannst
anschauen ganz spannend ist dieser oder
meinungsfindung im parlament wollte noch
das grundgesetz steht alle macht geht
vom volk aus
[Musik]
also das wäre zum gegenargument mehr
dass sie würden sagen das volk die basis
die beginnen mit ihrer meinungsbildung
über das internet über leicht
zugänglichen medien und kristallisiert
sich was raus und ich meine so war es ja
so integrieren hat dann darauf reagieren
müssen
das ist
da darf ich noch mal eine fotoleinwand
der hier vermissen
wer das wirklich zu sparen ich habe es
nicht genau verfolgen ich müsste die
ganze noch mal vor augen wir führen aber
das hat schon erwähnten gestrahlt
[Musik]
das finale gesetzt menschen das waren
fast ein bisschen positiv ist sehr
schwierig das war fast ein bisschen
positivistische von dieser rasen kommt
mit fakten und sonne und eine lesung
auch obwohl sie sogar bei der abi ball
auch informatik studieren weil der
verband also offensichtlich also
interessantes phänomen also spannend sie
haben jetzt den druck aufgebaut politik
wichtiges thema ich werde in einer der
letzten sitzungen wir haben in zwei bis
drei wochen geht jetzt zu ende bis zum
ende zu und werde ich dann noch in einer
sitzung die der kultur der digitalität
es wird auf die politik der digitalität
csi qualitäten
nicht das ist ja die grenzen zu sehen
das ist jetzt ja da die und logische
frage auf die kommen wir gleich aufhören
das ist führt also jetzt zum nächsten
punkt auf den ich dann auch noch genauer
zu sprechen kommt werden
haben sie noch was zu dieser diskussion
sei sie noch aufgefallen also was man so
in kürze der zeit zum beispiel ist der
unterschied zu youtube
bei youtube können sie so lange
kommentare schreibt wie sie wollen ein
nutzer hatte mir ja sehr langen
kommentar geschrieben von zwei drei
sitzungen hatte er das auch die frage
nach technologien und virtualität hat
die er in anderen vorstand werde sich
harting diskus präsent waren sehr langen
kommentare das ist der vorteil von
youtube ich muss ja was sagen dass ich
gemerkt hatte habe auch selbstkritisches
oder einfach ein erfahrungswert als ich
die tagung live gestreamt seite
gab es keine youtube ist kam diskussion
hat mitte april auf dem stück gab es
fast kann
was hingegen manchmal bei youtube dann
der fall es ist wenn die videos ganz
schöne beine drauf sind die werden wir
alle archivieren
dann kommt zu langsame diskussion
zustande also zwei wochen dann immer
zwei jahren
ich habe jetzt zu einem video hier
fragen kommentar den kompletten sind
zwei jahre
es waren aber keine live stream video
ist das waren so sitzungs videos mit dem
marcel mich gerade das sei der vorteil
bei twitter verhalten darauf sehr
schnell er gibt sein sohn als er das
vielleicht auch noch wichtiger punkt ist
es gibt eine struktur
sie haben also hier den betrieb gibt
auch besseres deutsches wort beitragen
die meldung wurde während haben
und natürlich das eben in der hardter zu
kommentare also erst recht dann gibt es
aber auch die möglichkeit den schweizern
also zu tageseltern würdest dessen
andere kontexte bedienen sich natürlich
einen beitrag in einem bestimmten
kontext werden wiederum teilen und dem
ich ihn zum beispiel mit einem häkchen
versehen und dann wird der selben
inhalte dieselben thesen wird sich aus
einem ganz anderen licht beleuchtet
das heißt ich kann diskussion viel
bessere perspektive struktur
alle sollen
eine marke oder jetzt auch noch die
installation des gewichtung da wo sie
eben absehen können wie erfolgreich der
base die indikatoren sind sicherlich
nämlich wie häufig wurde er geteilt
hier habe ich wurde er geweiht und wie
häufig wurde er kommentiert es sind drei
faktoren die ausschlaggebend sind für
die wertigkeit welche dieser drei
faktoren wir uns als wichtigste anschaut
kommentieren teile oder likes was ja
beteiligt seien
die beiden suchen
gemeint ist dabei genau das sehe ich
genauso
dann könnte man jetzt mal mehr kulturell
das soziologische politische studie
machen nicht mehr das machen am beispiel
dieses tweets von donald schon über die
kim jong-il diese atombomben diskussion
das greife ich auch von herrn lauer gern
neben herrn walter weber eine
professorin passau und der darüber firma
geschrieben von
das galt auch und wird ihn der bei der
rezeption resolution heißt man könnte
sich vielleicht der neue mitglied der
girl awards abkürzung zum facebook gerne
was man auch unter christen unternehmen
in san francisco san francisco und es
sind das lustige ist zwar groß ich habe
dort einen aufenthalt gehabt vor ein
bisschen mehr als ein meter in san
francisco und ich habe direkt einige
neben twitter wurde habe ich es nicht
wagen weil es war vielleicht hundert
meter davon entfernt
und dieses viertel des sommers und
heruntergekommen sehen sie als
drogenabhängige jährlichen tag an sind
ganz ganz schlimm wirklich eine die
taumeln darum und man muss wirklich
aufpassen
inmitten mit fensterplatz ist und dann
jetzt die riesen zwitter zentralen also
nun mal so hin als das unternehmen würde
aber nicht sondern ich glaube nicht die
gläser
doch nicht geschluckt ich glaube es
endlich gestoppt worden aber es ist eine
sehr mächtige sind sehr sehr gut frage
ich hier gefragt das unternehmen renate
also ich glaube aber auch dass es mit
youtube mich harmonieren oder youtube
auf ein altes prinzip setzt youtube
setzt nicht auf die schnellen
beteiligungsmöglichkeiten und umsetzt
auch team kommentare die lang sind auch
die auch nicht sondern auch die große
aktualität twitter wissen dass auch noch
wichtigeren absolut auch aktualität es
bezogen das ist ganz schnell
und wenn das ereignis herum ist beliebt
sie immer so ein paar aus
aber dann ist die sache auch einen
abgeschlossen das so meint meine
sehr situationsbezogen hat trump wie der
wird vielleicht nochmals neu waren
müssen sich meine statistik anschauen
in medias zeigen nachdem mit akzenten
diese botschaft des welche arten von
aktivitäten klebt und wieder ein
bedauern aber dass es ziemlich schnell
ziemlich schnell rechtsanwalt veraltet
und bei youtube ist es erst unter sich
zur aktualität noch ein bisschen länger
hell ist nicht ganz so zeitgebunden
aktualität geboren und deswegen glaube
ich dass ich gar kein oder guten tag
haben die macht immer jetzt youtube
könnte google das model kein interesse
genau ich kredit haben muss es wieder zu
schlucken weil es weil ich bei google
auf anderen
jetzt nämlich so aktuellen teams
beziehung setzen wir auch können sich
die games setzt auf datenmanagement und
datenauswertung und das ist bei twitter
um mich so geben man hat natürlich das
nicht immer auf der burg
ja aber schon aber ich glaube dass da
nicht so viel mit persönlichen
informationen finde ich glaube tweets
sind wir so von politiker politikanalyse
und trendanalysen wichtig es ist
sicherlich auch ein wichtiges datum vom
lager aber ich glaube es gibt andere
dinge die der kunde wichtiger sein
können aber solche vermutung ich bin da
kein experte und dann man könnte zum
beispiel auch in das hin zu machen zum
thema ökonomie der digitalität
riesending das thema vielleicht wir
sitzen wenn die kulturen in politik
werden auch thematisieren ökonomie der
digitalität mich je mehr theoretischer
wert berichtet wird die unterlage auf
dem jetzt gleich zu sprechen
es kam gleich noch das tal wichtiges
einfach zu sehr ist dass es 100
die ganzen anderen portale wie sie sagen
zu google dienste wie facebook wer auch
alles zusammen bereit uns oft wissen
alles großunternehmen die eine diese
marktmacht haben es tatsächlich nur ein
leben das ein produkt und dadurch
unabhängig ist ja das wäre sicherlich
ein guter punkt werden die frage ist
inwiefern gibt es wirklich noch ihre
unabhängigkeit
bei diesen unternehmen haben gefährden
ist da wirklich doch so ein interesse
dahinter
die wollen ja alle geltend zu machen und
mit fähren twitter wirklich so eine
freie meinungsbildung überhaupt wirklich
entweder rechts mit werten konfrontierte
beeinflusst werden das system der
informationellen selbstbestimmung
da ist viel mit ihm seit jahren also das
ist dann aber wieder punkt wo ich sagen
dass medienkompetenz
wir müssen und so kritisch sein dass wir
zum beispiel habe ich noch nie
angesichts der online
also da glaube ich nun diese grenze
selbst noch waren und wie finden sie
auch online werbung direkt zu reagieren
ob das in direkte reaktion gibt es ist
eine andere frage habe ich reagiert dann
auch einige auf online werbung
wenn ich ziemlich konzert aber es war
okay dann gehen wir jetzt zur heutigen
sitzung das thema hat ihn nämlich der
unternehmen die vitalität für jemand mal
ganz kurz mal die leitstellen keine
kalorien besteht der unterschied
zwischen einer physikalischen einer
virtuellen konto besteht und virtueller
handlungen
worin unterscheidet sie sich
verhandlungen
dies und der wirklichen welt bringt dich
jetzt und unvernünftig
einfach ein paar spielen welche und
theologie besitzen digitale gegenstände
zersprungen können wir in digitale
gegenstände erkennen als sie mich im
verhältnis stehen wir zu digitalen
bestände wie existieren digitalen
nebenstelle rauchen zeit existieren sich
behaupten andere zeit
meine these ist 610 nicht im auto
vielleicht ein bisschen zeit aber 610
auf eine ganz andere weise raum zeit als
das physikalische institut nämlich nicht
raum zeitlich wie gedanken dass ihre
frage und quasi wie gefühle nicht in
raum und zeit existieren richtig also
gefühle nehmen uns ein
sie haben da schon eine gewisse struktur
sie können uns als körper nicht gewesen
einnehmen aber sie können sie nicht
beschlägt sein
das gefühl ist jetzt da oder da dass das
ist unangemessen kategorien vergeben wir
haben zu sagen können der
evaluationsgruppe ist da hier zu dieser
zeit
sie können durch halb zu dieser zeit
haben st
gefühl da das könnt ihr sagen aber sie
würden gar nicht sein die zeitlich
ausgedehnt ist wissmann
und seine streng prüfen vielleicht sie
haben das gefühl von dieser zeit bis zu
diesem zeitpunkt
sie sehen es wird ganz schwierig da
überhaupt zeit ich zugeben ja im rathaus
gemacht
[Musik]
kennzeichen ausgegeben hatte
unsere weiteren arbeiten in diesen
sprachen hinaus tun aber das ist schon
wichtig aber der kommilitoninnen fragte
nach dem quali und ein quader es gibt
etwas was gilt unabhängig von seiner
herkunft geschichte also ein quale ist
einfach etwas was gegeben ist und es
existiert nur in seiner gegeben hat
wenn ich jetzt ein rot eindruck habe und
habe ich den rot eindruck da kam mir
irgendwie ich kann mich da enttäuschend
dass sich dabei um apfel oder was auch
immer
und ich kann mich nicht damit
dass ich jetzt wurde der demokrat ist
als virtuose und so vernimmt war ihr
ganzer phänomenalen erscheinen und die
andere frage ist dann rindern vor
ja was ist es jetzt in genau dieses ziel
oder warum habe ich dieses gefühl was
soll man das gefühl sagt dann fangen
diese bewegungen ein wenig allem aufs
gefühl fokussieren sich jetzt
möglichkeit und habe ich immer wieder
fehlende möglichkeiten bin ich wunschlos
gezogen würde ja auch immer mit den
möglichkeiten produziert woher sie
kommen
genauso wenig in roth haben bis
inklusive
tatsächlich weist mir irgendwie ein
verrückter wissenschaftler ein völlig
natürlicher mehr nämlich für die tat sei
sie wissen dass ich jetzt eben das
quartal das heißt man darf da ganz auf
der phänomenalen ebene bleiben weil
solches wenn sie quasi wenn es um
gedanken geht dann kann man weiter
fragen wie kommen darauf anzusprechen
aber qualia sind alle ziemlich einfaches
phänomen weil sie ganz im gegeben sein
auf die interessiert einfach
eingebracht weil es einfach dieser bi
zustand in quali kann ich mich gar nicht
nominieren
bist du eigentlich schon zu ordnen den
analogen bereich
ja das ist eine spannende frage als ich
habe hier noch mal diese übersicht und
ist wie gesagt nicht kennt und die wir
jetzt auch heute wahrscheinlich
modifiziert werden können
also sie fahren wir jetzt als ein quale
wie zb sand eindruck wurden wie das
meinen sie denn damit wie das realisiert
wurde wie das erzeugt wurde
es ist der asiatische automatisch der
marke werden ja in gewissem energiewende
wir ja es ist es ist vielleicht ein zu
starker spieler ja genau was ich kann
wenn ich ein quasi habe dann habe ich
jetzt erreicht
für mich wird das typische ich es ja
muss mit kramer belegen liefern nicht
nur die frage zu beantworten kann ich
meine ich kann natürlich auf eine rot
eindruck erzeugt bekommen durch zb seine
eine 3d brille des so aber letztendlich
wird er natürlich dann als es ist
eigentlich völlig egal welchen unter
druck bekommen
für den oder druck ist es egal welchen
bekommen ich habe ihnen damit ist alles
gesagt und in roth eindruck als qual und
ob er jetzt mit seiner abschlussrede
erzeugt wird
letztendlich kam sie rechts sind signale
durch dann in mein auge drehung oder die
meinen sehr reizen die gewisse bereiche
im gehirn hetzen müssen dann muss er
sich fragen wie es diese reizung zu
verstehen gehirn ist sie analog digital
spannende frage wenn es was
physikalisches ist würde ich ihr noch
diese spannende frage wie die
gehirnaktivität bewertet werden müssten
geschichte ist ich würde natürlich kann
man jetzt sagen der datenverarbeitung
gehirn hat was von der bilanz für den
digitalen datenverarbeitung
aber wenn ich würde sagen dass diese ist
eine biologische entität und insofern
zellbiologische entität ist passiert sie
auf analogen als bisher not weil sie
nämlich letztendlich diese die selber
perfekte dass wir das nicht
unterscheiden höhe ist den so
geschaffenen stetigen differenziert
waren natürlich ohne jetzt ist wieder
diese frage die funktionen die mit so
einer schwellwert funktion so ein
bisschen arbeiten
da gibt es dann eben - o2 zum stern aus
dann könnte man wieder sagen das ist
eigentlich eher was fürs digitale
spricht aber ich würde jetzt mal
biologe steht ist bis sie analog zu
erstatten
diese kurven und 14 ich glaube wir
einsicht gehören
wenn man sich mit underweight
sie können mit casino konzession selbst
digitale signale aber nicht unmöglich
jetzt dass sich das wir können mit
interessiert es nicht wieder los also
korrekterweise geben da nicht diese
schon kurz danach so genau weil es eben
immer gewandelt ist irgendwie und nicht
dieses konto um hat es das ist hier in
die welt
was ich das ist eine recht gefallen da
hinten der kommilitonen
mit den händen unserer seite das ist das
zwar unterschrieben haben die meisten
haben jeglichen computer eingeben oder
später einmal von dessen computer
zurück ins gesicht und wird auch das
gebaut habe was mir noch nicht gemacht
also der medienarbeit umgekehrt werden
das vernichten muss es also sein gesund
ist daraus ein sehr viele wähler
entschieden das thema sich die bau tagen
geschlossen würden
auch das ja als es ihr habt wirklich
welche man muss immer so ein bisschen
aufpassen
neben den computer mit dem geringsten zu
analysieren
das ist sicherlich ein punkt den auch
einen richtig trifft wenn er von der
animismus spricht es gab da so ein
bisschen auch korrekturen an
ich hatte ja auch gesagt wenn die da
drüben hatte künstliche intelligenz zu
ziehen man in verbindung war dass er
hatte eigentlich kannst du sie kennst
reduzieren auf algorithmen und da hat
ihn daraufhin der referentin
widersprochen auf den tag nicht also ein
bisschen und korrekturen angebracht ich
habe leider kein link mehr oben aber ich
würde dann hier eben jetzt in den kram
machen
es gibt dann muss man eben noch zwischen
semantischen typischen semantischer
zwischen diesen verschiedenen verfahren
denken
und man sollte jetzt glaube ich nicht 1
1 in mit algorithmen beschreiben
natürlich lässt sich in der rolle des
netz durch algorithmus anheben
aber es hat so kannst du sie kennst hat
vier verschiedene patienten verschiedene
bereiche grund geht lassen sich wohl
nicht nur durch den zukauf algorithmen
angemessenes leben so jetzt komme aber
zu diesem aufsatz zur philipp bereit und
ich habe mir den geschickten aus dem
rhein aus dem rock scott hamburg auch
virtual tape oder ganzes für mich im
wegweiser aufsatz über den physical
society und würfeln
bis 10 als virtuelle welten können
sagen wird schon die realitäten die
haben eine physikalische seite wird ein
soziales
und es gibt es ja die einleitung und ich
habe eigentlich auch schon vorgelesen
das war in einer sitzung wo wir erste
gedanken dazu hatten um oder ging es um
virtuelle gegenstände zwar virtuelle
realität die wir hatten und virtuelle
realität ist eben eine ontologische
frage wer sagt jetzt hier folgendes
kamen beliebte bauprojekt zu löschen
bayern wird wie ihre familie mit dem
modischen auf reporter virtual access
vpn software beim kunden zu grauen space
physiker und chemiker kabarettist bei
youtube im internet treff in der junior
suite zur existenz der just imagine
virtually im kontrast has no 6
installiert erzählst du welt beliebt
rica mit word vision und project
response to capitol in puts blatt
aktuell sieht es also da wäre jetzt der
einwand virtuelle äpfeln zb
unter spiel das ist ein virtueller apfel
der ist nur eine simulation eine oder
eine imitation vielleicht auch nur eine
fiktion wie auch immer eines
verwirklichen
er hat kein gewicht keine masse keine
physikalische forschung im raum und die
zeit kann man das aber gut in der zeit
wo man spielt ja sagt aber eigentlich
ist der apfel im programmcode drin
die apfel ist entität im in der songs in
der quelle
wenn sie sich den apfel als code
anschauen dann bekommen sie da eine
gewisse größe eine gewisse sie bekommen
auch digitale eigenschaften des apfels
wenn sie sich den quellcode des
programms anschauen aber sie können sich
waren in dieser im quellcode bis keine
andere problematische wirtschaftszeiten
wenn es ist auch keine eigenschaft keine
angaben über zeitliche die qualität
bleiben wird also das ist glaube ich ein
wichtiger punkt und der apfel kann auch
nicht wer interagieren sehr gut kanal zu
interagieren
gut wir können mit dem hcl interagieren
das ist doch wichtiger punkt irgendwann
wir ein computerspiel spielen aber da
könnte man sagen dies interaktion
genießen wird
für sie ist auch zählt montag erledigen
eine simulation also
das zufall hat dem motto logischen wie
bitte
der apfel ist der wirt keine
physikalischen objekten ich kann
natürlich im computerspiel und ihr
projekt ich kann nicht mehr
eine physik engine kann nicht
programmieren es gibt sehr gute die
funktionieren fast so gut wie unsere
wirkliche welt wenn ich da irgendwas den
steinen unter rolle berechnete kompakte
computer haben wie er auflaufen muss um
wirklich dem lg gravitationskraft zu
entsprechen
das war jetzt entweder bei das heißt der
virtuelle informationen
es ist eigentlich ein paar dem hier also
den realen ab so einfach in diesen
was wollen sie eigentlich gar nicht aus
das ist wirklich problems jahres
innerhalb dieser neuen möglichkeiten an
der mauer ist auch genau das sehe ich
genauso
wir sollten nicht virtuelle realität der
imitation oder simulation zu stehen so
wir sollen mit gerade bist nicht weil
diese neue möglichkeit das heißt die
raum und zeitlosigkeit ist es so sehr
defekte defizit ist eine chance auch
wenn andere weiße dingen zu realisieren
und jetzt setzen wir weiter geht
börschel objects materialphysiker objekt
wenn dort kein sex habe in frisco texas
der medici gesamten physiker zu computer
hot and cold case that some virtual
wir gießen gehört jsg mit einem aus
monte play jazz betonen the way we can
und virgin money mit kontrolle von
exchange und vor allem kann sie space
for virtual world central ein virtual
instruments fb.me tamke personalie bei
dem sonst oft schon früher twitter
twitter hinschauen auftritte das ist ja
auch virtuellen ist eine virtuelle
diskussion und da kann ich natürlich
beneidet werden fast noch mehr wissen
sie warum weil man ja der ganzen
öffentlichkeit ausgesetzt ist ja die
halbe welt dann wenn wir jetzt einfach
da vorwirft dass ich in ihre gebete
anbiete
dafür nämlich richtig schlecht
angegriffen
da muss es könnte auch so was genau ich
meine war aber ein trainer muss sofort
formen es sei klar dass ich jemanden
arme
denn wikipedia verbot dazu bin ich dann
so eine paternalistische aufpassen
ganz schlecht wer also nehme ich es
natürlich nicht aber sie sehen solche
digitalen rituellen diskussion nie ganz
eigene dynamik entwickeln eine eigene
mit den normal diskussion gar nicht
machen können und zwar deswegen weil sie
die möglichkeit haben hier mit nein und
herstellern und damit gehen kommt es im
entwickelte dynamic wie sie so gar nicht
erreichen
das geht dann auf trennen ist sie
ansetzen müssen von montag themen und
perspektiven dieses thema der nation und
muss natürlich auch sagen häufig für das
dann auch unsere falsche richtung geht
das ist dann häufig auch eine gewisse
verfälschung dann aber so war es auch
mit der mz depesche von bismarck wenn
sie sich daran erinnern wir das gekürzt
hatte sondern ein bisschen sind stellen
also die kürzung nur will
vertreter kann dazu führen dass der
sünder einstellt nicht nur dass es
menschen gibt und das ist neben
kürzungen gibt die sich inhaltlich aus
würde gewalt zu verklappen und das ganze
etwas entstehen können
das eben auch diese tendenz der ja die
seite sehr schnell wertigkeit das nach
informationen gleich aus haben muss und
das häufig auch nicht mehr so genau
macht geprüft wird ob das jetzt wirklich
korrekt als der twitter kann das nicht
erkannt gewählt der beste argumente
sondern ist der kampf der meist mit der
meisten likes das heißt hier kommen dann
wieder so eine messung des positivismus
ins spiel
höher schneller weiter dass die meisten
likes entscheiden sind entscheidende der
beste argument also eine argumentation
wird ersetzt durch so quantitative dinge
mit den spitzenreitern
ich sage nur es ist eine kunst natürlich
auch und wir wollen uns nichts vormachen
das war schon immer so diskussionen dass
man oder auch ein erfolgreicher politik
dass man argumente verkürzt hat oder
verstellt dazu läuft politik aber also
die die absolute herunter
drei betreuer nachricht gibt es nicht
dass interessen spielen aber ich würde
sagen diese stupide raum zeitlich sehr
um gebundene form erleichtert sich
demnächst also es konnten heißt es die
gesellschaftliche relevanz marke so
etwas kann das normale das gesetz ja für
mich also ich kann jetzt also ein
städter von allah hat eine kiste äpfel
geglaubt so
dann schreiben sie hier habe ich
niemanden sieht das nicht und im
nächsten haushalt verlassen
richtig aber sie würden doch auch sagen
dass twitter also eine gewisse macht
also dadurch dass dort anschauen
und er macht es ziemlich gut also auch
er macht es ziemlich gut wirklich dieses
medium für sich zu nutzen klar der
einfaches denkens die aber auch wirklich
geschliffen sind also das ist schon eine
kunst wenn sie sich einmal die wir
schauen aus dem man dank meiner guten
wie donald trump twitter tweets
abgesetzt
in welcher situation wir wieder zurück
oder das ist eine hohe kunst
das ist ich kann so was nicht
also es machen sowie den aus dem badisch
oder also wie gesagt es ist es ist eine
kunst so weit so ich finde die idee
nicht von dem
saniert diese dimension von twitter
perfekt zu nutzen
eine scheinbar perfekt abgestimmt ist
einfach dieses medium hatte genau den
kanal für sich und das wirklich immer
live vortragen können weil wenn sie mal
schauen wie viel in leipzig habe mit den
betrieb noch angeschaut werden diesen
nordkoreanischen präsidenten wie viele
likes und liefere teilungen das hat es
auch unglaublich und das entwickelt der
eigene name und da muss man auch das ist
als ein sprachrohr verstehen dass man
entsprechend bedient es wäre instrumente
auf dem man spielen muss
werdet das zwitter instrument versteht
der hat ein riesenvorteil
wer generell werden die vitalität
versteht also instrumente zu bespielen
sich so darauf einstellen und die
nachrichten so proportioniert und
gestaltet und verortet und verlinkt ja
ein riesenvorteil heutigen zeitpunkt der
hauptmann der zukunft zu wissen da wird
alles der haut oder immer mehr nur noch
über solche dinge laufen und die träume
sind bringt bekommt große probleme man
zieht es sich auch ein bisschen beim
traditionellen verlage die kämpfen ums
überleben
ganz schlimm sehr wenige große verlage
dominieren alles kleinverlage kriegen
ihre sachen nicht mehr weg und dann muss
man hier wirklich im detail
spannendes thema also ich glaube
kurz gesagt es gibt natürlich virtuelle
beleidigungen die eben auch real sind
wird sprecher eines tiers nicht los
immer mehr sind es sind eben beleidigung
die auf eine andere weise realisiert die
nicht von mund zu mund kommuniziert
werden dass ich jetzt jemanden von ihnen
hier beleidigen
was sage ich das ist ja auch gerade noch
mehr beleidigen die bestehende hinter
meinem rücken und diese werke und
räumlich geschichte absurd dass sie gar
nicht halten das sind manchmal steht
dahinter eine nutzerin
aber es kann auch eine beteiligung geben
die analytics das macht das ganze noch
viel schwerer als wenn ich jetzt hier in
jemanden beleidigen und du hast
natürlich nicht und sie haben dann
mischt sie sehen mich und sie wissen wer
es war und zu können und direkt
antworten hier gibt es das problem dass
man gar nicht mehr direkt unbedingt eine
frage wie es kam noch ein letzter punkt
schachspieler das ist glaube ich ein
virtuelles jahr spiel ist ein
schachspiel war es eben nicht am holz
schachbrett vollzogen wird so was jemand
bildschirm und es gibt da ganz viele
tolle mannschaft spielt nicht nur
nochmals anschauen dann auf youtube
können sich anschauen
ganz toll mit erklärung das sind dem
großmeister die live sogar noch einmal
spielen und dann erklären jetzt will ich
mit dem bauer dahin aber hier sollte
eher wahrscheinlich dass machen
das ist natürlich virtuelle realität
weil das schauspiel gezählt ich würde
sogar folgen das behaupten
der begriff der scharf simulation ist
ein widerspruch in sich
[Musik]
mannschaft kann man wenn man es spielen
dann spielt man das dann ist es wirklich
im spiel bringt in der realität drin
es gibt keine chance es gibt vielleicht
eine chance nationen gehen an eine
künstliche intelligenz da wird ein
anderer spieler simulieren aber da bin
ich mir sicher da bin ich sie gab sonst
kann die simulation möglicher ernst
werden zum beispiel kasper noch gegen
die blue man sich nur 19 695 verliert
dann hat es eine reale bedeutung das ist
nicht nur simulationen gewesen dass er
wirklich dem draht und dem trat der
schweizer und verstirbt im kreis bekannt
deswegen will ich sagen schade
simulationen im falschen begriff das
immerzu wald ist betrieben wird gemäß
den regeln wirklich spannender punkt
die skype-software fans have been center
software social studies und wie viel
geld sie für den tarif von tolle die als
thema der heutigen sitzung unter
lonestar die auf bühnen mit sap-software
question of what kein cities xl 105 1
auf systems play together und all just
quest schon zwei gläser deshalb physiker
haben jetzt alle auch weg damit risiken
dort ist der politik und moritz relate
to check out medizinisches zentrum für
mich kontingent properties auf autos
oder defence of existence braucht ihn
vor ort nächsten moment ist es aber es
hat kein wind für fischer robin sofort
das theologische fragen und sie sehen
und louis hat nicht über
vom physikalischen dingen zu tun die
hier greifen kann sie können sich nach
der onkologie einer zahl fragen die 25
existiert sie platt und manchen plateau
mit dem wind sagt 25 existiert noch viel
mehr als zum beispiel hier diese wer mit
dem team eine handschrift oder
physikalische objekte tun
das ist eine ideelle entität oder
dateien wie gesagt es gibt so was idee
des baumes den tauben existiert hier für
sozial schwache nur dank seiner
teilnahme an dem die idee des baumes
viel wirklich nicht sehen anfassen zu
bleiben ist noch nicht ganz ganz
interessante fragen wie existieren
mengen ereignis existieren immer ein
fiktionales objekt hamlet existiert
haben existiert überhaupt mit chatter
wird reform internat schicken alles ist
auf virtual objections und events markus
willi und theaterleute questions wurdest
du moravek systems wird oder ob die
reaktions und events kentucky bershawn
jackson sentiments geklärt ob früher
wird es im postulat reality app baut das
display ist
das ding schon mehr als den virtual card
in der sky lounge giftpapieren realität
zwischen triberg und florence der fläche
werde teams potenzial habe ich schon
präsentiert verbergen dass der nicht auf
dem college unsere wirtschaft kein
konstruktives sein
eine lösung wird schon im wandel
rechnung während es ist also es gibt
momentan in große unsicherheit über die
begriffe wie verhält sich realität zur
virtualität ich glaube der fehler erst
als bauträger ist virtualität gegen die
realität auszustellenden kannst du
willst es gibt eben
ich glaube man muss es anders machen
muss so machen
[Musik]
die der menge in der realität die kammer
von anderen zwölf moment der realität in
der schweiz und im bereich der realität
der mobilität gibt es nebenwirkungen des
karnischen und ist nicht gleich vom
mieter zum beispiel war natürlich dabei
ist er vielleicht eines tages karl spitz
und virtuelle realität ist einfach ein
teil erreichte realität zum beispiel ein
virtuelles schafften oder den meeren
fischen können sie gehen auch die
mediathek mit haben sich bis jetzt
endlich etwas was die fahrdaten existenz
überhaupt und italien in den tisch was
er sagen das ist alles und wir dürfen
glaube ich nicht den fehler machen
virtualität von realität und er schafft
es zwei kategorien sondern es ihr so
realität ist der überbegriff virtualität
ist nur eine form von realität ein teil
des kaders haben müssen verriet er
möglichkeiten entscheiden kann
dann wäre auch so was wie die fiktionen
wirklich sind
zu sehen dazu keine wirkliche situation
klar aber simulationen sind nicht real
weil sie ja nur ähnlichkeiten habe kann
ich bekannter machen und das sind eben
von losen möglich erscheinen und die
möglichkeit den thc wirklich ist weil es
ja noch nicht wirklich ist das wäre auch
noch möglich aber als ich hier die
devise jetzt habe ich hier wird das team
schon die queen reality twist der
entscheidung nicht auch wir müssen
verstehen werde mich jetzt entwickelt
das die verschiedenen bereiche teilen
von realität und dann nimmst die
physikalische realität
eigentlich eine physikalische realität
gesagt wo die physikalische realität
gibt es keine geben der zumindest
irgendetwas geht ist ja das ist dass es
mit guter punkt man als es wäre die
frage nach der realisierbarkeit zb wenn
sie jetzt den roten roth eindruck haben
dann können sie eben das quali nicht
erklären vollständig durch die
physikalischen bedingungen durch dieses
erzeugt
sie erklären ja sie können ja den
blinden nicht den roten druck erklären
oder vor augen führen wenn sie sagen
cv somit diesen teil des gehirns oder
molekülen sonst so oder neurotransmitter
sohn so das können sie alles
physikalisch erklären sie können doch so
eine lange physikalische erklärung nicht
an
und dann können sie versuchen hier so
eine physikalische erklärung
diese klammer und sie können die chips
machen noch so perfekt für sie keine
studie das findet was da genau dann zum
gehirn film gar nicht wo geht sie werden
und natürlich haben wenn es diese
geschichten die physikalischen gegen
einen linzer bringen dann wird ihr am
ende nicht sagen jetzt habe ich den
eindruck als sollten sie wird sagen okay
gut dass das kann nicht alles
nachvollziehen
aber was ist denn jetzt bitte schön rot
und sie haben schon recht sie man muss
schon in die unterscheidung die jesus
und geld und sie haben jetzt abgerungen
auf die chinesen das ist in die frage
dann können würde ihn fast zustimmen zu
wollen wir wissen lassen sich eben
bewährt und auch virtuelle realität und
physikalisch realisieren also wir
brauchen eine gewisse physikalischen
wie computer gewinne was auch immer um
das zu erzeugen aber in der geltung ist
es halt auch immer währenden ebene
angesiedelt als mit dem physikalischen
reduzierung und es wäre vielleicht
möglich ich weiß nicht aber diese
theorie das ist zahl gibt und zahlen
wären dann ist eine spannende frage ich
zu müssen da auch die mathematiker
fragen und es gibt durchaus auch
mathematiker heute enorm
mathematikerinnen die würden sagen
zahlen existieren
und wenn sie dann daneben dann sie das
problem dass sie dann schlecht erklären
können wie zahlen physical übertrieben
realisiert so also zahlen wer zum
beispiel geraten würde
die platonischer wird sagen ideelle
gegenstände sind für die verschiedenen
physikalischen bestimmen und zahlen sind
zum beispiel wenn es die zahl drei gibt
oder die menge weise war es ja bestimmte
menge dann existiert die füllen
unabhängig von physik sie können sich
sogar eine zahl vorstellen die existiert
wenn es keine physikalischen gegenstände
geben überhaupt nicht instanz juristisch
oder deswegen ende der offiziellen linie
die in jedem satz ricanischen diese
theorie wurde
vertreten sie wird auch immer noch
betreten wird auch nicht von so vielen
denkerin und denker als deswegen würde
ich mir wirklich sagen genauso auch mit
ton umzug aber ist gespannt
frage und wie machen wir weiter of the
exception exception paper 1 1 hatte
förster distanz alles daneben
virtualbox interviewte physiker ihre
frage wie es mit dem physikalischen
zusammen meinte der chairman der unter
90 installiert als virtuelles leben
stehen
der sexualforscher ist und dass zecken
christian wurst da die an der ybbs
circumstance welche auf 6 mcf einer es
fehlen des würden profi internet domain
auction und taunus ich habe darauf schon
mal abgebaut und sozial in der
vorwärtsbewegung der virtual action
unseren ort
[Musik]
15 euro investigate the space und mit
virtual diesen trade of confusion ort
uncertain and hence das ding schon mit
ruhm
wir haben fiction und ein komplott x6 m
reisender verhandlungsunfähig will
discuss the city wissen ja also da hat
sich einiges vorgenommen ich halte
diesen aufsatz für sehr verdienstvoll
kommen und jetzt kommen wir hier auf die
general und vision und realität zu
sprechen generelle regel eine theologie
des stv kerns wende first pressechef des
rewe-konzerns mode praxis und herrschens
juventus mehr frauen mit männern
objekten dürftest du nord systems dms ja
diesen absolut zu
der bsc rob brown auf den bürger also
fallen hier hinaus im amt an
digitales abgibt er sagt die fallen
jetzt wieder aus weil es besser sei wenn
wörter objektiv neue system and the
scenes klären ford-werke object storage
system virtual experience of user
support oder bmbf ins mittelfeld und
internet will vertrauen can say that
some think city center ist nur während
ja also das heißt es da
ich glaube der autor also ein bisschen
kritik von mir ich sehe es ein bisschen
anders du musst du immer diskutieren
ich glaube er vermischt zwei dinge und
zwar gibt es in computerspielen dich als
einzelspieler spiele sicherlich alle
möglichen gegenstände die sich zb
irgendwelche äpfeln oder sie sagen ich
würde aber nicht wirklich sagen dass ich
das diese dinge virtuell existieren
und zwar deswegen
weil sie bloß simulationen würden das
unterscheiden von simulationen
er spricht jetzt aber im gleichen
kontext von von virtuellen umgebungen
als er denkt ihr oder computerspielen
als ein online computerspielen und da
interagieren wir tatsächlich mit diesen
die bestände zu dass sie ist eine
virtuelle realität bis jetzt nicht da
auf eine blaue jeans kennen also ich
glaube dass der autor hier richtig
unterscheidung nachvollzieht zwischen
eine bloß simulierten jährige stand
gegen simon commander keen wo sie seine
pistole übrigens commander keen ergänzte
spiel genau das war das mit der schnecke
commander keen haben es gestern entdeckt
können sich sogar online multiplayer
spiel natürlich schatten dann bekommt
das ganze noch ist das aber kommen
entschieden haben sie eine pistole wie
interagieren würde ich sagen nicht
wirklich mit dieser strecke mit dieser
pistole und da wird was simulierte
werden
zum einbezogen durch die version der
blaue party uns käme geben der ist
virtuell existent unserer deswegen weil
der nicht nur was simuliert sondern ganz
klar in werther der verhandelt wird und
zwar im rahmen an das sozial und also
mit anderen freien wesen die da auch in
diesem online rollenspiel interagieren
die gemeinsam mit mir diesen wert ist
auch mitbestimmen
und das ist nicht der vereinsspieler
politisch darüber die lipizzaner haben
die gegenstände nur den status als 100
zu ich kann mich zwar auf sie beziehen
insofern kann man sich fragen wie sein
die gerade für unternehmen geschaffen
aber er ist nicht auf diese weise real
virtuell wie ist der blaue party und
ausruhens kenntnis ich glaube dass das
hier dieser auto mich richtig richtig
sieht ist meine meine these
existiert
möglichkeiten dazu
hier existiert müßig zu sagen
würde ich sagen kann schon existieren
auf dem 30.06 wird auch drüben
ja ja ich würde es aber niemals realität
natürlich kann ich sagen mit diesem
spiel und das wird sich mancher fragen
in diesem spiel existiert
klar kann ich sagen wir wenn man die
vereinigung der begriff jaja es gute
bruder punkte wird also digitale
gegenstände existieren sicherlich sie
sind im krieg und verankert sind dadurch
objektorientierte sind
objektorientierten dinge also wenn ich
im spiel programmieren objektorientierte
programmierung unter uns die ganze zeit
wieder sichtbar was ich mag
objektorientierte programmierung und da
entscheidet ihr auch schon konto
logische voraussetzung enthalten sein
dass dinge ihm konstruierten werden aber
die existieren eben als simulation würde
ich sagen wir haben alles so könnte man
sagen können
im normal über die existenz andere dass
wir ihm auch eine lektion und eines 110
berechtigte fragen die ich würde
vielleicht sogar auch gesagt
möglichkeiten möglichkeit versus
wirkliche funktion und es gibt mögliche
fiktion
ich könnte mir irgend eine fiktive figur
überlegen aber ich habe es mir nicht
belegt ich kann jetzt irgend eine
fiktionale figur einfügen einen
einführen die nenne ich irgendwie xyz
und jetzt habe ich es gemacht und jetzt
ist er aber ja alles weil wir nicht
interagieren kann zur wand zu fahren
und als ich würde sagen billiges
objektorientierten parade marx in
computerspielen der werden objekte
abgegrenzt wird sie werden mit dem ziel
das ist ja existenz wichtig die werden
abgehoben zum anderen objekten der
umgebung aber eben modus der simulation
und mich im modus der virtuellen
realität das ist es worauf bauen kann
ich kann wirklich diese identitäten
digitale dinge auch so eine schnecke in
kommentieren das entität sie existiert
im spiel klar aber es existiert modus
der sänger dazu kommen und nicht mehr
modus der der realität der virtuellen
realität und häufig eben existenzen und
virtuelle realität und eins gesetzt
ich glaube dass das problem ist dasselbe
virtualnights helfen
bis zehn spiele von virtual hauptsitz
ist das ist gerade punkt leben jetzt
nicht also ich würde sogar sagen dass
eine schnecke dem commander keen bis ein
virtuelles objekt wäre bereit das
zuzugeben aber es ist keine virtuelle
realität als es deswegen objekt weil ich
mit ihnen sicherlich interagieren kann
im modus des monats ich kann nur
deutschland empfänger und 7
wer spielen kann ich umgehen kann auf
diese schnecke schießen sie wird
ontologisch abgrenzbar von anderen
entitäten aber sie ist keine virtuelle
realität weil sie nur eine simulation
ist das wäre meine haben und sie wird
dann sind im virtuellen realität wenn
sich inter subjektive gemeinschaft das
sozial und theologie darüber ein und ist
massiv an wert
stichwort blaue partnern im juni eine
anklage partien von skate existiert das
dann wird es probiert und er ist eine
virtuelle die l wird wenn
alle einen wert hat den diese schnecke
nicht hat diese schnecke kommt nie aus
dem spiel raus diese schnell dass wir
eine simulationen wurden in fiktion aber
sie wird nie einen wert besitzen den ich
zb umtauschen kameras oder über dem ich
mir einige werden muss bekannt das ist
irrelevant wenn ich jetzt commander keen
aber multiplayer spielen und seit
gestern weiß ich dass man commander keen
multiplayer spielen kann dann bekommen
die sie entrollen
denn sie wird mit dem eben diese hinter
suter bei späten aber auch deutschland
existiert kein fußball-leckerbissen des
virtual access formulieren
auch herbert forstwirtschaft uns gewiss
ist
da würde ich ihnen widersprechen also er
sieht das jetzt macht eine andere chance
ich finde ihn nicht überzeugen
das ist der computer virtual office
immer schon das während alisa als nah
als auch digital und legte die etwas nur
mit ihren so wäre es wichtig aber der
blaue partien gut fahren debattieren
nicht diskutiert der blaue panther mut
der simuliert vielleicht auch was aber
er hat mir eigene realität dasselbe bmj
wird ist ein billiges schwimmszene wären
dort wo wir es entdeckt und ex ist also
äpfel sind keine wirklichen etwa das ist
wichtig aber es existieren
als problem beide ex ist es wenn apple
das gleiche mutation state of play
plastics ist mit action virtual reality
just not that all das ist schon richtig
aber der blaue band ist eben ein
wirklicher glaubt die rot der eine ganz
klare kausale kraft hat mir ein
und der franzosen imitation geschieden
werden
der blaue wagen der verselbstständigen
sich von seinem vorbild das dann am ende
gar nicht mehr wichtig ob ich jetzt
immer gut ist sind diese tendenzen
gegenstand der etwas von bedeutung
er hat an wert und diese dimension kommt
mir so ein bisschen zu kurze diesen
beschreibungen werden spielereien nicht
beeinflussen
auch stinken andere genau problem genau
das ist auch meine eigenen
zwischendrin immer alles möglich hält
inzwischen tauschen
da die wunde werten steht das bedenkt
dass es zum beispiel des pokémon hat als
dieser prognose haben die so selten
gebrauchten ist entweder das vielleicht
die gleichen
ich würde dir zustimmen und es hängt
davon ab ob wir uns eines sozial
anthologie befinden nur dann wird meine
these mit dem möglichen raum stellen nur
dann haben es den virtuellen realitäten
zu die auch digital sein kann wenn
wiederum spricht und jetzt möchte ich
mir hier ganz kurz ein bisschen vor
springen
[Musik]
und zwar kommen jetzt hier welchen sinn
des patents zentrale punkt kann nicht
mehr viel zeit
mehr das neue motto sex in workshops
selbst wenn es ein action sci fi center
jugend mir waren bin - simuliertes und
zu fragen können virtuelle gegenstände
die auf existierende irgendwann digitale
apfelwein im single- und wer spielt
erstmals eine gravierte
objektorientierter objektorientiert
programmierte apfel können die wirklich
mal als real derzeit werden im gegensatz
zu großen simulation situationen
während das team mit virtualbox aber
mehr ist hat dieses leben ob dieser
dialog in fonds oder das
retracementlevel feiert mit virtual
access im rock it in some cases via
instant referiert examiner exelixis
instead of mary post merger of the
present dasselbe männer word und excel
liste mit ex-mann ist moderiert max in
csr computersimulation virtual access
single agent uri ihren hut mit dem
virtual assistant manager zu
qualifizieren und oder ob sie können
praktisch das finde ich sehr gut zu
machen und reportagen sexshop members
auf der classic days and promoting the
physical work by witch space prinzip
ja da bin ich mir nicht mehr so ganz so
wie es der berliner experte kennt
crossfirex das ist die entscheidende
frage gibt es das festkonzert in der
physik und check up des volks und
recycling mit virtual network version
der app ist gratis can never kornfeil
instanz ist fließend gewesen ist netapp
der hedging fristgemäß als ganzes
competition is essential for the future
of work 600 helfen heißt nordhessischen
komposition und wer vor ort realisiert
werden
das ist in welchen räumen stuff physiker
rainer kern der vermeintlichen topstars
keller war zander fleisch und ipad 2
computers 211.000 prognosen fürs
geschäft helfe kaufen auszug für die zum
teil vom physiker phänomen das ist
wirklich phänomenal control ist auch
neid auf sound denken sie an den ton
spielen dieser center spielen der can do
service computersystems input output
weißes wanders klicks ersten 1000
jugendlichen in pretoria fundamental 13
boote und ermordeten teenager swisscom
ende des liedes sound shapes im kampf
konsumenten welche version räumen
orchestra plays beste karten für und die
meinen das würde eigentlich keine
orchester spielt eigene ordnung
es gibt dann gibt das orchester fassung
der von adobe
das ist alles wieder in ordnung ist für
reformen soft hat ein flug in die
meinung des networkings seminar oder
löschen weil man den service von
gewissen medien service center ist
die vereine der firma oder konsistenz in
der play this but not bei der national
physical object trading märz also wenn
sie am computer ein kreis sein ist ein
wirklicher grasdorf das kann eben eine
simulation verwandtenkreis dabei ist
nämlich hier oder bei st
die ezb kann am computer können sie im
kreis auch realisieren und zwar einfach
eben durch die definition von der
unendlichen anzahl von punkten die von
einem produkt den selben rennstall wie
sie eben kreis ist definiert
ok ja also das finde ich ganz hält also
jetzt geht es um die frage was da
computer dem reproduzieren können wo
jetzt noch ganz kurz johnson johnson
johnson erst die bälle oft unter laut
stoff viel redet kann erzählt in der
kanzel petkovic kein sex shows und
events eishockey-liga nhl pony continues
to steal things can be und steckdosen
wird schon vorn service in what we can
convert fundamente des menschen kennen
die maid betonte physiker in social and
physical and princess zum ende diesen
effekt sogar janet jackson den pendenten
presentations auf der dem baum existiert
auch wenn wir nicht zu jenen gewarnt
wenn wir keine repräsentation gegangen
ist so schon relativ konsistent jenny
bocklet bad outcome for cancer research
interpretation einen construction also
zb universität unternehmen geld das sind
alles soziale und das ist hier noch mal
die chance finde ich ganz grandiose idee
geht natürlich zurück auch andere denker
auch schon hegel mit seinem begräbnis zu
kritischen geistes und des absoluten
geistes hat da eigentlich auch schon
sonst
oft aber unternehmen geldschein und wie
ich meine auf
dort existiert leben gemäss einer sozial
und honig gemälde der physikalischen
drücken und die sozial runde geht
bedeutet das ist meine kritik an zu
nicht nur dass wir uns intentional durch
unsere gerichte teile ganze kollektiv
internet
und das wird dass freiheit nicht
vermisse in der mitte muss frei
interessent schließt uns darüber einig
bin der mensch uns heute aus sie noch
ihren bereich hatte die überprüfung zu
warten wir was wäre ihre lösung für
besucher konnten quasi zwei staaten haus
zitiert
sondern dass ich immer zu diesen
scheiben weniger sprachen ausgedruckt
und dem was die möglichkeit diesen
werden vielleicht zum ausbacken sprache
gebracht das heißt das geld ausgeben das
gemütliche die eigenschaften haben
ja das ist setzen erkenntnistheoretische
frage du dich auch sagen eine
mythologische erkenntnistheoretische
frage
wir würden jetzt hier einfach nur mal
hoffen der begrifflichen ebene bleiben
gehört einfach mal unterscheiden wird
die welt konstruiert
die welt ist auch eine schwierige
begriffe
es präsentiert der so gar nicht gereicht
also auch die realität ist ein sehr
schwieriger begriff dementieren müsste
ich glaube dass man hier gar nichts dass
er erkennen dass theoretische
bedingungen anstellen müsste oder
methodologischen einfach ist über den
praktisch was sehen wir als real an was
existiert auf diese welt und da würde
jeder sagen universität existieren auch
sie hat gewisse rechte zb dass ich jetzt
unterrichten darauf das darf ich dank
der existenz der universität dass sie
hier meine studierenden sind und als sie
benoten kann letztendlich natürlich base
auf bass mit gesetzen und zwei weitere
hochschulen wir setzen also die zuvor
mehr als wissen gebäude ist auch dass in
rechtskurven auch ganz ganz genau es ist
ein rechts körper und diese rechts
körper existiert eben nicht physikalisch
bieten ist wenn in eine begriffliche dem
instrument das man einfach zu springen
ok jetzt kommen wir den nächsten gang
ein vertreiber mich jetzt wir werden in
der nächsten sitzung der noch mal drauf
eingehen die folien verlinkt ich hinter
unter diesem rat diesem video macht sie
sich noch mal anschauen können alles
gute bis zur nächsten sitzung in dem wir
dann noch mal kurz auf den changi
eingehen genauer gesagt auf die sozialen
theologie der digitalität der
kontinuität und uns dann ein thema ethik
der vitalität widmen was mich ein ganz
wichtiges thema
schon wieder auf diesen punkt teilweise
zu sprechen kommen da wird schon ein
schönes wochenende bis zur nächsten
sitzung gesagt